i might get canceled for bringing this
up right now but i'm going to bring it
up anyway because i'm not scared pat
but as you're saying this social
contagion and munchause syndrome
and how basically you want people to
feel bad for you because you want more
attention you want more attention
the name that comes to mind for me
speaking of trans of who's the face of
trans these days
caitlyn jenner
bruce jenner yeah so i have a theory you
tell me if i'm crazy if i'm wrong if
i've got it all wrong feel free as pat
says tear me a new one whatever tear
down my argument i've been around bruce
jenner all right people that that follow
the podcast people know i used to be
friends with
chris humphries and kim kardashian i
used to be in that kind of world for a
little while and i spent a lot of time
around bruce jenner this was when he was
bruce jenner
and all he talked about was the 1972
olympics was it 72 or 76 76 montreal
okay that's all he talked about gad okay
keep this is 2011 all right and you know
we're getting ready for the wedding i'm
a groomsman in the wedding right like my
boy's about to marry kim kardashian and
he's like come here adam and he's
helping me like fix my ties like let me
tell you when i was in the 76 olympics
and what we did i was like this guy
really talking about the seven like this
is what his story was and my theory is
this he's surrounded by women
right kim chloe kendall this one that
one all right chris all the k girls
and he's the one guy right
and well there's the brother but he kind
of was like shunned um and they're
getting all this attention and eyeballs
and eyeballs and eyeballs and if you
fast you know rewind he was the
decathlon winner was the biggest name in
the world at one point and now he's like
an afterthought in this feminine world
and at some point he said you know what
i've been a man's man for 50 something
years
now i'm caitlin
now all the eyeballs aren't me diane
swords interviewing him he's he's what
was he woman of the year he was women in
like 2016 whatever it was
so all these eyeballs around him look at
me look at me look at me so am i crazy
for identifying this as sort of some
sort of uh what do you call it social
contagion munch houses syndrome am i
completely operative
take it
uh so i don't know enough about his his
personal story to be able to confirm if
it's not i mean
you certainly have a set of causal links
that might make sense uh but it seems to
me that it would be it would require a
big behavioral commitment for him to
engage in all that he's engaging simply
because he wants that kind of attention
i mean did you get a sense that he was
starving for attention when you would
interact with him again his only claim
to fame
via you know up until 2016 was that he
won the olympics in 1976.
so anytime like imagine if you're citing
all your soccer stories from the 1980s
right it's like at some point it's like
god we get it you played soccer but
what's up now yeah yeah it's like if pat
only talked about being a bodybuilder
and he had nothing else to offer yeah so
at some point you're like you know what
this might get some eyeballs anyway
that's my have you heard him speak have
you heard him in interviews have you
heard him give
his point of view in perspective have
you actually seen him why are you
calling him him
oh no
i met him i met him yes when 2003 and it
was tom hopkins seminar yeah i mean we
have a picture together but when you see
him speak do you see him as a person
that is
have you seen how he answers questions
how he processes issues
then or now today
uh yeah i've seen him a little bit yeah
i mean he's very you know he's kind of
like woke but on the right right
republican but lgbt it's kind of
confusing yeah he doesn't come across to
me as an airhead
uh he comes across as a very uh the way
he gives us answers and processes issues
and
he doesn't come from an angle of feel
sorry for me or sympathy it's a very
interesting uh uh
you know situation with him when you
when you hear him speak but it's also
kind of confusing but but it is but but
so there's a part of what you're saying
maybe makes sense because
it's very very hard for you to
walk into a room and get all the
attention
and all of a sudden you walk into a room
you're not even in the top seven of
getting all the attention right that can
really and and i'm talking about in your
own family yes so it's okay if you go
out there
and you're getting all the attention and
then all of a sudden you go to a
different environment and another person
is getting all the intention but it's
not your family
then you go from in your family you're
the guy that gets all the attention then
all of a sudden it's your wife then it's
one of your dances they're like all of a
sudden you disappeared hey guys i'm also
important here too that could happen for
you you bring up an amazing point you go
from number one in your family and there
was no doubt in there zero doubt yeah he
was number one and then boom boom boom
boom boom daughter famous daughter
famous white famous daughter famous
younger daughter younger daughter and
now you walk into a room or you go into
a red carpet and they're like hey would
you step out of the way we're trying to
take pictures of all the ladies and he's
standing in the corner and at some point
he said you know what [ __ ] it i got to
become a lady
i might be crazy here but there's some
element of like this is going to be this
is going to sound strange for me to
bring this up but i mean whoever
interviews
him to have this conversation if he's
it's a personal question but
you know do you think he's had
any kind of a
sexual experience with a man since he's
had this
see
i i and let me explain to you why i'm
going in this in this direction like
this is not i'm not being silly i'm not
being i'm not at all trying to be funny
or sarcastic at all
because
if he has
then it's a desire if he hasn't the
motive was a different motive yeah it
was just to get the attention
you know what i'm saying right like i
could be wrong but i still think he
likes women yeah i think he's just
identifying as a woman now yeah so now
could be wrong he's
yeah i could be wrong
yeah so i don't see him hanging out with
dudes and it but but again
go go back to the power of the power of
peer pressure
the the power of peer pressure being
around you the power of you know the
eyeballs the the power of what fame does
to you
the power of some people don't know how
to handle fame early
you know the power up when it's taken
away right taken away being an
afterthought yeah but like like you know
like okay so you know how think about
how much it sucks to be
michael jordan's son
okay yeah think about that like one time
i'm having a question what's his name
again
exactly exactly so one time i'm having a
conversation with one of my guys and i
said you know what's more annoying than
a bad example he says what's that i said
a great example he says what do you mean
i said okay so kid who had a let's just
say a bad example as a father let's just
say
you know that kid's got a point to prove
to outdo the father so then he does and
he becomes a better man than his father
but it didn't take a lot to earn that uh
what do you call it that uh
stature you know i'm more successful
than my dad okay so now you got what you
wanted you've done better you're a
better man than your dad is now flipping
and put your dad is
a person that is very powerful and you
have to outdo that person okay but now
go be that father
and that father who is on top of the
world and everybody thinks nobody's
gonna out to you and then somebody does
so i think i think in those cases the
best advice that i can give the child is
to not follow in their parents footsteps
i agree right so for example your dad is
michael jordan become a neurosurgeon but
that's this is not even the conversation
the conversation is what if you are
michael jordan
and your son out too out does you right
that's this situation because he's chris
you know he's you know the guy who's
bruce jenner you know crushes it and
then you're everywhere you go you're
that guy now your kids do bigger than
you they're more famous than you they're
more successful than you they're richer
than you
how does he process that it's a very
different situation that he's going to
speaking about montreal 1976 olympics it
would be i would be remiss if i did not
mention the fact that my brother
was in the same olympic village as bruce
jenner because my brother was an
olympian in the 1976 olympics in judo
that something happened between them
is that kind of where you're going i'd
be remiss
they were in the locker room yeah and
next time hey guys it was just locker
room talk it nothing happens another
thing uh by the way i i think you guys
are mma guys are you right yeah yes we
have them here all the time so before
before the whole thing with mma started
where the idea was can you get guys of
different
fighting traditions to go into the
octagon and fight each other i had had
that conversation probably 15 years
before the mma came came to be with my
brother who was an olympic
judica and i
my brother is is really small of stature
but he's a bulldog right and we would go
to clubs in southern california in the
early late 80s early 90s
and he always walked as though he's six
foot eight right he just has this this
confidence about him you know we'd be
interacting with bouncers and so on and
i would always say to him
do you think that you would be able to
take this guy and so so to as a
preemptive thing of the mma as a pre
he would say god as long as the guy
doesn't knock me out
as i'm approaching him if i get him
he's finished and that's exactly what
you would see in the mma now where the
guys who can take you down on the floor
are usually the ones the khabibs of the
world right so my brother was already
saying that as a judo cup you know back
in the late 70s and early 80s maybe you
could put them up anyways that's it is
that michael jordan put up put up
godzilla's brother by the way i want to
apologize to our audience our young
friend tyler over here googled michael
jordan's son and michael b jordan the
world famous actor showed up that is not
that michael jordan's son
i i hope he'll be happy that i'm giving
him this uh that's your brother that's
mine david sad david sad
so he used to be a badass that's what
you're saying look look at those look at
this go to this
let's this is him huh no that's me
that's you that's jesus with the h guys
stop the poundcast let's just get it let
me let's what's going on here right now
are you questioning your sexuality right
now oh
holy moly god this is so listen then it
makes sense then it makes sense why you
got a model out there that you call your
wife you know that by the way she she
told me many times yeah how come i never
got the eight-pack
and now i told her she's left i'm only
with this guy now i'm not eight-pack now
but i'm sort of closer to this you're
back baby i'm back baby
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]